on aura également non mais je peux pas
citer mission c'est n'importe quoi
qu est ce qui va tenir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rassurez vous rassurez-vous le gars
c'est pas un imposteur
il revient pas pour nous vendre hitano
cia dégage chez eux et se met encore une
véritablement copains je garde donc en
faire sobeys a fini munga mais non il va
venir pour son nouveau single
voilà
honte à nous
dans ce temps s'arrête
allez
tous ont d'abord de nous engueuler
m
[Musique]
tous cas ce n'est pas grave
oh
[Applaudissements]
je peux mettre duquel dix pendant une
heure et demie sans
content de marquer tube les bons vous
voulez vous les donne c'est mon équipe
elle ajouté
[Applaudissements]
m
on va compter le nombre de tubes qui l'a
fait en si peu de temps que j'ai déjà là
on en a on en a quatre
regardez plus maria maria peut pêcher à
celle là et c'est une de mes préférées
c'est la cool
[Musique]
un deuxième album carton aussi avec près
d'un million d'exemplaires vendus
on y retrouvait une de mes chansons
préférées d'agrément
non
[Musique]
kenji sur la tête de ma mère quand tu
comprends pas la chanson c'est un après
tout c'est qu'il est en voiture il
s'embrouille avec akon qui nakina après
les faits quand il sort la bonne était
basse de l'automne arrivé de lagos et
tout une histoire d'hommes
la priorité c'est brûler n'guemo ça veut
dire je me chauffe avec la musique voilà
un câlin bien cette solution vous dire
une petite musique un verre de fanta
citron quoi les gars tu ne vois plus
quoi c'est un jour j'étais avec des
copains mais parce que moi il faut
écoper en fête le week end venu pour de
périph ont fait que des tours de périph
online dans une voiture ils auront
pourtant on roule en voiture comme ça
quoi mais pourquoi pourquoi
oui parce qu'on aime rouler les sens il
n'a tellement pour brûler les sens qu'il
fallait et on a pendant trois heures on
n'a mis que cette chanson ah ouais ouais
et on l'a mise comme ça on l'a remise
remise mais on n'a mis que ça n'allait
jeu damas comme ça et on chante et on
était six dans une voiture les yeux de
la mama se jure et apprendre à finir le
poste
[Applaudissements]